bonjour nous sommes le 18 septembre
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv fil 78
voici les principaux titres de votre
journal d'actualités locales le passage
de la ligne 18 sous une partie de la
ville de voisins-le-bretonneux ne fait
pas que des heureux les riverains
viennent de monter un collectif
ils s'expliqueront dans un instant sur
ce plateau une pme qui marchent sous
mécatronique travaille depuis à 25 ans
dans le secteur de l'aéronautique et le
succès est au rendez-vous de nouveaux
locaux viennent d'être inaugurés sens
saint quentin en yvelines et puis nous
reviendrons sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine comme chaque
vendredi mobilisation contre la réforme
du collège colère des maires contre la
diminution des dotations financières de
l'état ou encore solidarité envers les
migrants solidarité qui s'organise à
bonnel dans les yvelines les invités
donc de ce vendredi guillaume c'est bio
et martial jourdain bonjour à tous et
bienvenue sur ce plateau fondact
fondateurs du collectif de la
bretonnière à voisins-le-bretonneux un
collectif contre le passage de la ligne
18 du grand paris en souterrain sur
votre commune qu'est ce que vous
reprochez dans les grandes lignes au
tracé actuel on a vu l'infographie le
tracé actuel c'est celui qui est en
rouge le vert c'est celui que vous
proposez on va le revoir dans un instant
qu'est ce que vous reprochez au tracé
actuel écouter ce qu'on reproche déjà
c'est le manque d'information et de
concertation de la part de la société du
grand paris
puisqu'on a découvert
très récemment donc en mai 2015 que ce
tracé est passé sous la bretagne alors
que précédemment en 2013 tous les tracés
du grand paris indiqué que le métro
passerait à côté du golf sur des zones
non habitées
nous ce qu'on reproche s'il voulait à ce
tracé aujourd'hui c'est qu'il va passer
en souterrain sous environ 400 pavillons
qui sont donc des maisons de plain pied
donc nous ce qu'on craint énormément
c'est les nuisances déjà donc du bruit
des vibrations et en plus les maisons
ont été construites sur des terrains qui
sont un peu instable vous avez peur ça
ait des conséquences sur la solidité des
ouvrages environ et surtout que
l'expropriation nos sous-sols nous
empêche ensuite de pouvoir consolider
nos moyens éventuellement on va revenir
sur tout ça dans quelques instants
auparavant un mot sur l'actualité il y
avait à dire jeudi à versailles comme un
air de l'amour est dans le pré les
jeunes agriculteurs d'île de france
organisée au monument café leur premier
agri dating avec un objectif simple
permettre aux jeunes agriculteurs de
rompre un peu plus avec l'isolément
auquel ils sont souvent confrontés en
organisant une rencontre avec les
citadins c'est un volume un moment
convivial au programme animations et
dégustation des produits du terroir
forcément une manière d'ouvrir le monde
agricole au grand public
on a ça existe toujours
des jeunes agriculteurs qui sont dans
des fermes isolées ou nouvelles
qui vivent avec leurs parents qui
reprennent l'exploitation familiale
donc ça surtout été fait ça pour les
amener ces jeunes là à sortir un petit
peu de leur exploitation à rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes
voilà vraiment voir d'autres horizons
c'est pour faire des rencontres plus si
affinités amicales amoureuses moi je
vais les laisser faire je vais juste les
séparer pour éviter que l'on parle de
tracteurs toute la soirée et qu'ils
aillent par les tracteurs avec des
citadines
on passe à l économie à présent à magny
les hameaux l'entreprise sous
mécatronique qui vient d'inaugurer ses
nouveaux locaux spécialisée dans
l'usinage mécanique des pièces de haute
précision pour l'aéronautique et depuis
plus de 25 ans la sarl recherchait
depuis 2012 un local plus grand pour
regrouper l'ensemble de ses activités
soutenues par la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et la ville
elle a fait l'acquisition d'un terrain
de 5000 m² williams elle pour les
détails su mais quatre onic une
entreprise familiale qui perdure c'est
sarl de 25 salariés basés à magny les
hameaux vient d'inaugurer son nouveau
parc de 5000 m² plus grands le bâtiment
de 2000 m² permet aujourd'hui
d'accueillir l'ensemble des machines
outils nécessaires à l'usinage mécanique
de haute précision et répond également
aux nouvelles normes environnementales
ça crée évidemment d d d emploi puisque
on achète des machines donc on a besoin
de les alimenter
néanmoins on a quand même des problèmes
de recrutement dans notre métier non
conformes sur le tard
recrutés localement ici il ya de la
place s'il ya de la place pour la
formation pour apprendre un métier
avec les difficultés pour le secteur de
recruter des ouvriers spécialisée dans
l'usinage de haute précision su mais 90
privilégie la formation des employés en
interne
j'ai eu qu'un seul ap mécanique de base
et puis je suis arrivé ici comment
dirais-je au plus bas de l'échelle
donc j'ai tout appris sur le tas cubain
aujourd'hui je suis opérateur sur
commande numérique espions p 3 ce qui
fait que j'ai évolué en dix ans de trois
échelons de base je connaissais je ne
connaissais pas le métier avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 5 millions d'euros
annuels et des clients comme thalès ou
le groupe safran l'entreprise est une
véritable valeur ajoutée pour le
territoire
elle a bénéficié d'un soutien de la
casse qui est de la ville pour l'achat
du terrain et trois nouveaux postes
devraient également voir le jour
rapidement
guillaume sebileau martial jourdan les
fondateurs du collectif de la
bretonnière à voisins le bretonneux qui
sont donc en plateau aujourd'hui pour ce
journal au mieux quelques instants vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure ce tracé qui
pose problème on tracé de la ligne 18 du
futur grand paris on le revoit ce tracé
en rouge c'est ce qui est prévu en vert
c'est ce que vous souhaitez la ligne 18
pour repréciser les choses c'est cette
ligne de métro automatique en rocade qui
va comprendre sur le papier le 3 gare de
correspondance à l'aéroport d'orly massy
palaiseau versailles chantiers
elle traversera six communautés
d'agglomération plus de 840 milles
habitants elle sera opérationnelle vers
2020-2030 même si le tracé rouge est
maintenue vous disiez tout à l'heure qui
aurait expropriation de vos sous sol
faire vous n'aurez plus possibilité
ensuite de renforcer ses sous-sols si
les maisons vos maisons qui sont
installés sous cet ouvrage était
fragilisé c'est ça tout à fait une somme
sur des zones dargis environ 12 m est ce
qu'on est ce qui risque de se passer que
le tunnel c'est un assèchement de la
nappe phréatique
nous avons déjà beaucoup de maisons qui
sont sous micropieux généralement à 20
mètres de profondeur nous savons que le
tunnel lui va passer à 14 mètres de la
surface donc actuellement par rapport au
tracé il ya un barrage de micropieux et
nous demandons effectivement à ce que la
gpr étudie son tracé un tracé
qu'ils soient en zone pavillonnaire
parce qu'effectivement il ya la voix
tcsp qui pourrait faire passer ce tracé
une partie du golfe concernant practice
sa passion sur le practice de golf qui
se positionne sur une partie du practice
et le gros avantage c'est par rapport à
ce tracé ce qui les 400 mètres moins
long ça représente des dizaines de
millions d'euros d'économies
mais je pense que c'est important alors
si c'est du bon sens pourquoi est ce
tracé là n'a pas été retenu justement
vous l'expliquer écoutez c'est la
question nous avons posé là la gp madame
le maire c'était du grand paris
voilà cependant la sucrerie madame le
maire donc à préparer une réunion avec
les riverains de façon à ce qu'ils
soient au moins informé par la gpe la gp
s'est engagé effectivement à étudier un
deuxième tracé
mais nous savons qu'à l' enquête
publique le tracé en rouge sera maintenu
avec une zone croissant à ses linges
concernant les zones madison et là
l'inquiétude effectivement est encore
plus grande c'est qu'il ya beaucoup plus
de pavillons qui seront impactées par un
futur tracé dans une union où on zoome
l'ignorons aujourd'hui le la la
définition est ce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre c'est que vous nous expliquer
que c'est un terrain friable et très
bien peu solide qui va être utilisé mais
on imagine pourtant qu'il ya des études
qui ont été faites avant de proposer ce
tracé soso vos habitations
alors effectivement il ya eu des forages
qui ont été faits 1 40 m de profondeur
pour écoute pour étudier les couches
géologiques donc le tunnel pourrait
passer dans des couches qui sont
présentes à partir de 15 mètres de
profondeur de 15 mètres et au delà qui
sont et couche dure donc ça ne pose pas
problème en au tunnel ce qui pose
problème c'est les couches supérieures
et les fondations nos maisons en fait ce
sont des couches argileuses et il ya eu
énormément de sinistres causés par la
sécheresse beaucoup de déclarations en
catastrophe naturelle est en fait il ya
beaucoup de maisons qui ont été réparés
réparer des micropieux donc ça la
société du grand paris n'a pas l'air
d'être
au courant de ces micro pieux qui
forment un véritable barrage de toute
façon au passage du tunnel
déjà il ya une impossibilité technique
forêt qui passe au delà de 30 mètres de
profondeur ce qui n'a pas l'air d'être
prévu qui n'était pas prévu on va tout
de même préciser aussi ce qui s'est
passé parce que la décision de passer
sous vos différentes habitations sur
voisins le bretonneux sur ce quartier de
la bretonnière ça a été décidé au moment
où il n'y avait pas de mer sur vos
ongles parce qu'il ya eu une période où
il ya eu un recours qui a été à déposer
annulation des élections municipales
nouvelles élections et pendant cette
période forcément pas de conseil
municipal
l'intérim qui était assurée mais c'était
juste pour les affaires courantes
l'impression que vous êtes fait un petit
peu à voir dans cette histoire sont les
communes limitrophes vous la société du
grand paris qui se sont dit bon allez on
va me mettre à son voisin bretons ne
pourra trouver dans des trials oui
l'ensemble l'ensemble de l'ue chinois
effectivement impression de cette femme
où c'est un peu le sentiment qui
prédomine il ya des recours malgré tout
parce que là vous tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé j'ai oublié la situation mais
quels sont les recours légaux qui
existent du collectif
on va passer en association et le mute
effectivement c'est de faire un recours
ou des recours mais oui ça veut dire que
ça retarde ray le chantier c'est
absolument
en fait le recours se fait sur à partir
du moment où il ya eu une décision qui a
été prise c'est à dire qu'il ya une
déclaration d'utilité publique
c'est celle là qui peut être attaquée
mais ça nous empêche pas de commencer
les démarches dès maintenant et nous
avons à notre disposition un certain
nombre de procédures y compris
juridiques que nous allons entamer
préalablement il ya une pétition aussi
bien sûr et une pétition et environ 350
personnes qui ont signé non on débute la
pétition elle va grossir mais oui à
beaucoup de gens de riverains et de vie
chinois mais très mécontents et en
colère même et tout ça doit se décider
aussi assez vite parce que même s'il ya
des modifications qui sont actés
finalement on sait jamais peut-être que
la société du grand paris va revenir sur
son choix mais il faut que ce soit avant
janvier
l'enquêté qui se déroule en ce moment
ces symptômes bon ça se passe un cap et
bep un angle comment comment les vies si
noir ou la possibilité de s'exprimer
comment ça s'organise alors en fait l'
enquête publique doit trouver un lieu de
débuter début janvier pour se terminer
théoriquement au bout d'un mois donc là
en fait les habitants ont la possibilité
de s'exprimer soit individuellement soit
en association donc en groupement
associatif
la mairie peut aussi avec les services
techniques donner un avis un avis
technique auprès d'un commissaire
enquêteur qui enquêtera certainement à
la mairie de voisins ou dans un endroit
dont vous appelez tous les vices ynwa as
manifestées se mobiliser et d'apporter
des éléments pour expliquer ce qu'il ya
des micropieux qui ont été installés
alors nous on est en train de constituer
un dossier technique très complet dans
lequel on va répertorier toutes les
réparations ont été faites dans les
maisons et peut-être faire une expertise
technique extérieur de manière à
démontrer que le passage
du tunnel à cet endroit là n'est pas une
bonne opération j'ai un peu le sentiment
que c'est le pot de terre contre le pot
de fer parce que comment vous vous
organisez vous dites on fait un dossier
technique mais enfin tout ça ça doit
coûter l'argent aussi
ça sera à nos frais puisque pour
l'instant la mairie n'a pas la mairie de
voisins n'a pas accédé à notre demande
de prendre en charge une partie des
actions ou des frais qui pourraient être
engagées pour l'instant effectivement on
est c'est le collectif qui va financer
tous à financer l'ensemble de ses
revendications qui se met en place si
malgré tout ça ça n'aboutit pas vous
ferez quoi manifestations ont fait
bloquer le chantier tout vous êtes
déterminé en tout cas à bloquer le
chantier est bloqué un tunnelier
celui-ci donc forcément mais ceci dit ça
aurait une vraie incidence si tout ça
s'était maintenue et qu'il y avait une
incidence sur vos maisons parce que j'ai
tout simplement les valeurs des maisons
qui le gros problème c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est que si nous
fallait le métro passe ou des maisons si
effectivement il ya des réparations à
faire nous serons plus propriétaire des
sous-sols donc ont pu intervenir pour
faire les réparations
c'est ce qui est c'est le gros danger
c'est ce qu'on craint le plus possible
et le deuxième point d'achoppement c'est
que effectivement la gp s'est engagé à
faire un deuxième tracé que
malheureusement aujourd'hui nous voyons
rien venir
si les habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux veulent vous
contacter pour mettre en place un
dossier technique renforcé votre dossier
technique alors c'est possible via un
site internet donc ils s'appellent
www.collectifvan.org la ligne 18 pour
l'info et il ya aussi une adresse e-mail
qui est contacts at collectif tira
bretonnière tirait lille 18 points info
merci à vous deux est repassé sur ce
plateau ce collectif de la bretonnière
collectif qui entend vous l'avez bien
compris obtenir la déviation de ce tracé
de la ligne 18 du grand paris et qui
pour le moment pas sous une partie des
habitations de voisins-le-bretonneux vos
habitations à sa merci à vous
comme chaque semaine nous revenons à
présent sur l'actualité depuis lundi et
pour commencer voici un résumé en images
le montage est signée romain respini
cette semaine commençait la semaine de
l'art européen de la mobilité qui elle
valorise le partage de l'espace public
et la sécurité des usagers
les français sont invités à repenser
leurs modes de transport et à choisir
également autre chose que l'automobile
la principale cible en fait sur les
déplacements c'est le domicile travail
les déplacements du quotidien donc c'est
pour ça qu'on vient parler aux salariés
de comment quelles solutions peuvent
vous apporter pour mieux vous déplacer
en bus par exemple tous les jours
vêtements couvertures produits de
toilette et jouer c'est littéralement
une montagne de dons qui a rempli la
salle communale samedi dernier à bonnel
les affaires presque tout prix y ont
déjà rejoint le monastère où sont
abrités les réfugiés arrivés mercredi
dernier mais ne manque rien tout ce dont
nous avons besoin est là et super je
remercie toutes les personnes qui sont
venues ici pour volta c'est un rendez
vous traditionnel la fête de l'humanité
c'est tous les ans depuis 80 ans
une fête une fête populaire une fête le
culturel une fête politique et cette
année comme une autre il y avait
beaucoup de monde vous malgré malgré le
temps cap à cap a repoussé tous les gens
qui avaient pris leur place a plus sa
place avant pardon et nouvelle
l'occasion de rencontrer des centaines
divine watts sur notre stand 1 le modem
qui vit à un drôle de mois de septembre
la formation de françois bayrou est elle
en campagne ou non pour ces régionales
en île de france lui dénier vous le
savez s'est rallié aux républicains
avant même le premier tour mais pour le
moment pas d'accord avec le modem sur
une liste commune
ce que le modem existe encore
aujourd'hui bah écoutez on est oui on
existe encore la preuve c'est qu'on est
dans les discussions si on n'était pas
en discussion pour dire ça y est on est
mort n'existe plus
une journée placée sous le signe de
l'agriculture avant de rencontrer le
réseau amap ile de france claude
bartolone le candidat du parti
socialiste aux élections régionales
d'île de france était aujourd'hui à
versailles en visite à l'inra pour
observer l'avancée des recherches dans
le secteur agroalimentaire c'est aussi
le moment de s'imprégner des
problématiques l'an l'occurrence de la
recherche de on a parlé beaucoup là des
doctorants des dépôts ce dock donc on
est avec des échanges concrets et c'est
de ça dont on a besoin aussi pour être
plus proche en termes de solutions
ensuite de des demandes et de la réalité
les nouvelles mobilisations des
enseignants contre la réforme du collège
la troisième depuis la présentation du
projet par la ministre il était à paris
aujourd'hui nous entendrons leurs
revendications la mobilisation
aujourd'hui vous voyez qu'elle est là
elle est présente à l'est autour de moi
il y à des enseignants qui malgré le
contexte de début d'année scolaire
chargée avec la reprise des cours avec
les réunions parents professeurs sont là
en masse
et en premier lieu selon le ministère de
l'éducation nationale 15 8 % des
enseignants sont en grève ce jeudi sur
toute la france pour protester contre la
réforme des collèges on continue avec
les communes les communes qui se
mobilisent le samedi 9 septembre un
appel est lancé par l'association des
maires de france qui appelle à la
mobilisation
en cause la décision de l'état de
réduire de 30% les dotations aux
communes et intercommunalités à saint
cyr l'école la mairie a même préparé un
cercueil symbolique le maire bernard
décevant se mobilisent non sans humour
plus d'une centaine de salariés de
l'entreprise gea de montigny le
bretonneux se sont rassemblés ce lundi
après midi pour faire grève mais se
mobilisent contre un plan de
restructuration
débuté en août 2014 et qui met en péril
une trentaine d'emplois avec une goutte
de sang en fait on mène 2 200 on
l'appliqué 15 minutes après si il y à
deux bandes
en fait c'est positif une bande c'est
négatif
vous avez aujourd'hui des gens qui
parfois toute leur famille ou des femmes
qui trompe donc leur leurs amis leurs
conjoints et pour le coup ils n'ont pas
forcément la possibilité d'aller en
centre de dépistage parce que parfois
les horaires sont un peu compliquées ils
sont effectivement donc en train de
travailler et là pour le coup c'est
compliqué d'aller voir son médecin
généraliste en dix ans j'aimerais bien
faire un test du sida
cette semaine vous l'avez entendu il
était question dans l'actualité locale l
actualité nationale de cette colère des
maires de france les diminution des
dotations aux communes amorcé l'année
dernière par l'état fragilise leur
budget et qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche ils ont donc prévu de se réunir
dans plusieurs endroits à travers toute
la france samedi plusieurs
rassemblements qui sont prévues et ce ne
sont pas les propos du ministre des
finances cette semaine qu'ils vont aller
calmer dans une période d' efforts de
réduction de la dépense publique
demander un effort aux collectivités
locales c'est la moindre des choses
les mots de michel sapin ce mercredi
matin ne devrait pas calmer les maires
de france en diminuant les dotations de
fonctionnement des collectivités depuis
2014 le gouvernement s'est attiré les
foudres des élus locaux
les diminutions qui vont atteindre près
de 4 milliards d'euros pour chacune des
trois prochaines années
pour le maire les républicains de poissy
de nouvelles et
conomie sont impossibles car le livre
mène d'ailleurs la fronde dans les
yvelines
il appelle à un rassemblement dès 10
heures ce dimanche pierre bédier
président du conseil départemental ou
encore à la députée valérie pécresse
seront présents quand le chef de l'état
de 2 milliards d'impôts en moins pour
les administrés fait de mes gars faut
bien récompenser et c'est encore les
communes qui vont qui vont passer à
l'addition moi je peux vous dire que
dans notre département
sur 262 communes c'est tout 200 communes
qui seront concernés certaines même
d'entre elles sera pas le cas parce
qu'on a anticipé les difficultés mais
certaines d'entre elles seront
incapables de payer leurs agents à mon
sens avant la fin d'année
car la contestation touche toutes les
communes de droite comme de gauche à la
verrière par exemple le maire communiste
explique que les services à la
population seront moindres et à
saint-cyr-l'ecole le républicain bernard
de bain elle a dit qu'il faudra jongler
entre ces suppressions et hausses
d'impôts
quand vous avez des communes comme la
ville de saint cyr ou depuis au moins
cinq ans en baisse de 5 à 8 % tous les
ans il arrive un moment où on ne sait
plus où trouver de l'argent depuis
quelques années pour le budget de la
verrière pour vous donner un exemple
nous ont perdu cinq cent mille euros sur
un budget de 10 millions d'euros donc
c'est évidemment des baisses très
sensible on essaye de mutualiser de
réorganiser
et mais cet exercice là une limite et
dans le budget 2015 tout comme dans le
budget 2016
nous commençons à réduire un certain
nombre de prestations en dehors de
poissy un autre rassemblement d'élus est
prévu ce 19 septembre dans le
département à rambouillet autour du
président du sénat gérard larcher et
nous reviendrons sur cette
d'immobilisation contre la diminution
des dotations de l'état dans notre
édition de lundi florane parfait recevra
notamment jean michel fourgous le maire
les républicains d'elancourt premier
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et on court
justement nous y partons dès à présent
pour la fin de ce journal alors que les
cours viennent de reprendre les plus
jeunes on retrouve aussi leurs
animateurs pour les temps d'activités
périscolaires comment sont ils formés
ces animateurs regardez les enfants sont
à l'école
les animateurs aussi ils sont là pour
découvrir le monde de la radio et le
proposer en activité aux élèves des
écoles primaires de la commune
nos animateurs sont formés par canopée
donc je rappelle que canopée et donc un
organisme qui dépend de l'éducation
nationale spécialisée dans la formation
pour les enseignants à d'ailleurs signé
une convention avec eux et donc l'un il
une forme nos animateurs plus
spécifiquement ce matin sur le sur la
création d'une web radio savoir rédiger
un texte faire un montage mais aussi
installer le matériel technique leur
formation se passe sur 40 heures j'ai eu
un passé dans la radio donc je retourne
un peu aux sources et ça me fait
plusieurs du coup de pouvoir plus tard
le partager avec les enfants sur les 170
animateurs présents sur la commune
d'elancourt vin se consacre t ap autour
du numérique
il s'associe aux enseignants volontaires
et peuvent s'exprimer
ils travaillent sur leurs expressions
et puis en même temps on va faire ça sur
un plan ludique les activités de
webradios commenceront après les
vacances de la toussaint et c'était ap
il en sera aussi question dans le
journal la semaine prochaine avec un
dossier à bilan sur leur organisation
dans les communes de saint quentin en
yvelines avant de vous laisser en
compagnie de mélanie poquet pour le 7-8
week end ses propositions de sortie pour
les prochains jours avec principalement
vous le savez les journées du patrimoine
un mot sur la programmation de nos
confrères de radio sensations dimanche à
18 heures nicolas kirillovitch ce
recevra alain gournac sénateur les
républicains des yvelines il sera
question de la crise des migrants des
frappant en syrie et bien sûr des
régionales écoutez d'ailleurs cet
extrait alain gournac revient sur le
départ très tôt en campagne de valérie
pécresse en ile de france il ya un
espèce d'usure
quand vous démarrez trop tôt les dix
pièces d'usure des malades ya dix ans on
l'a déjà vu mais ça l'est l'a déjà fait
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une aile
elle accepte d'ailleurs et l'euro
connaît où il ne reconnaît plus depuis
très intelligente et commentez l'enquêté
une très bonne ministre elle
je trouve qu'elle fait maintenant c'est
moi je suis sévère
j'adore valérie c'est pas parce que
comme sa rencontre lui dire tout fait
tout bien
c'est sensationnel parce que je sais
qu'elle gagne et oui je pense
sincèrement je vous dis qu'elle a la
possibilité de gagner l'intégralité de
cette interview sur radio sensations
donc avec alain gournac sénateur des
yvelines rendez vous en ce qui nous
concerne sur tv fait lundi 18 heures
pour un nouveau journal en direct toutes
nos éditions toutes nos émissions et nos
reportages sont à voir dès à présent en
replay gratuitement sur notre site
internet www.tfc.info mais vous en avez
l'habitude puis vous pouvez nous suivre
également sur les réseaux sociaux très
bon week-end à tous et à toutes